this is Star
[Music]
Talk all right this one from Greg fiser
on Facebook says hi uh Dr Tyson at all
uh I remember reading a while back uh
that in a Quantum State electrons were
shown to not only have spin but were
kind of able to jump or teleport between
and within their shells while this still
seems a bit far-fetched and not a
physicist hey thanks for that Greg
thanks for letting us know that you're
not a physicist cuz I was for one I was
very concerned um what's new and what
can be explained about this so Paul this
not specifically Multiverse but if
you're worrying about Quantum phenomenon
it's got to show up at some point we
know that when electrons jump energy
levels or even when particles what we
call tunnel from one state to another
state yes the time delay is basically
zero isn't that correct um a particle
can show up in one place having traveled
from another place if it tunneled there
it got there faster than the speed of
light isn't that
correct um is that the wrong way to
think about it I think it's the wrong
way to think about it I think there's a
a period of time during which its
location is uncertain and if you uh
account for that that lost time that's
the time it would take for uh that would
be longer time it would take for or
equal to the time to take light to
travel from its first location to the
other so it's like you would see it here
and then there' be a period if you
weren't watching that it would suddenly
appear here and then that would that
period of uncertainty would account for
the light travel time okay now the
period where you're not watching that's
a necessary that's a necessary part of
this phenomenon yes because to see it
would mean you'd have to be shining
light on it to see it now you'd be
cheating you'd actually be kicking the
electron and you'd say oh the reason why
it went from here to here is cuz I kick
it yeah so it's important that you don't
look
okay because then you're you're not
studying the tunneling phenomenon well
that's like the old joke uh I I I know
how to teleport and they say prove it
and you say okay I'm going to go to San
Francisco right now I'm back okay you
know what I mean
that'ss it works I can't just prove it
okay so just I mean you said something
fun and and deep as you have been doing
in this time you've been sharing with us
that uh for a particle to disappear from
one place and reappear in another
spontaneously via some kind of tunneling
phenomenon it does that because you
stopped looking at it the act of having
looked at it the act of looking at it
sort of keeps it in that Quantum state
if you will in this scen it out or or
kicks you look at it it kicks it out
interact with it now you're studying a
different effect right right and this is
happening all the time for everything
it's just that we can be illuminated by
light but our mass is so high that we
don't jump to another quantum State body
and soul but an electron is such low
mass and it has this interaction
capacity with a photon that you can't
shine a photon on it and expect it to
stand there and smile for you yes okay
wow okay yeah that's pretty awesome so
the act of trying to measure it changes
what you're trying to measure right you
can't measure it because once you pull
out whatever it is you're measuring that
actually affects it right and the New
Age movement completely misunderstood
this thinking that it's your
Consciousness that's somehow affecting
it and it's a human thing no it's the
ACT it's the active measurement is a is
a thing whether or not the human is
doing it you have to have a machine
right whatever doesn't matter right and
this spontaneous process by the way is
the same idea that's involved with
producing the Multiverse it's a similar
tunneling or Decay like process this
case it's a decay of inflationary energy
into matter and radiation that's
occurring randomly due to Quantum
effects and the fact that it's random
and sometimes produces a huge expansion
is all part and parcel of this Quantum
uncertainty Randomness gotcha Quantum is
some badass stuff let me tell you that's
that's crazy it's powerful thing yeah
and the fact is that uh I'm going to be
very honest I don't understand any of it
that's fine okay I'm just letting you
know no but but you don't have to by the
way by the way I Paul who was it say was
it fan so one of the one of the greats
of yesterday year said the day you say
you understand quantum physics is the
guarantee that you do not because it's
not something to understand just is oh
right okay well then I feel much
better no you just no no we we were
freaking out we our our our historical
Brethren who discovered this that they
they were freaking out just like you are
right now right oh my God a particle a
wave why who what Einstein said God does
not play dice people were freaking out
even Einstein so you in good company
even today even today people still
there's still a community of people that
debate the interpretation of quantum
mechanics and then there's another
community of us who just say just it
just this is it shut up and compute
compute exactly I'm in that I'm in that
camp this is Star
[Music]
Talk